[Music]
michael is in miami hey michael welcome
to the ramsay show
hey dave hey guys how are we doing
better than i deserve sir what's up
uh not much uh i'm uh 28 as you said
here from uh miami and i'm self-employed
i would manage my to get myself out of
60 000 in debt which took me uh about a
year to do yeah and um yeah thank you
sir and uh my question is uh i'm
currently renting now and i've managed
to save up 550 000
and uh i honestly don't know
what the best thing to do as far as
investment wise and i'm honestly looking
into buying a house and buying the cash
and you know i know you're the perfect
person to talk to about it so i want to
um you know see what the best way to go
about it is dude you went from 60 grand
getting out of debt to 550 000 in the
bank like it was nothing what the flip
did you do
oh well i i took a lot of lumps in uh
like four different businesses that i
started one of which was the reason i
got into the debt you know because i
started with like five thousand and the
rest was credit card so i made some big
mistakes when i was younger
and i've always been a serial
entrepreneur and you know this last one
i started uh it's going on a year and a
half now i've due to all the mistakes
i've learned from have allowed me to
make it uh make it work okay so you just
you've you hit a lick with your business
all right good and it was kind of after
you got clear of the debt
yes sir wow that's interesting well
before
technically now you have to struggle to
get out of the debt and then that
allowed me to be in a position to start
the business and then
make it work not off of that i'm saying
the 550 000 all came
after you cleared the debt
yes sir yeah that's what i was trying to
get my heads around good good for you
well done proud of you man
i feel that feels pretty studly doesn't
it
oh man it's it's amazing you know the
challenges come up and you just gotta
persevere and uh you know stay true to
your gut yeah
so have you looked michael at houses in
your area that you want to live for that
amount of money
oh yeah i can get a
nice 1-1 around here in miami these are
some of the most outrageous prices i've
seen and part of the reason why i'm
still renting is the red hot market and
i know the market's kind of tapering
down a little bit around you know
everywhere else but uh
you know it's it's rough out here yeah
it really is yeah one and one's about
all you're going to get in in miami
proper in dade
for that because that's it's an
expensive market it kind of thinks it's
new york
um
wow i mean pretty pretty cool okay so
here's the thing
a couple of observations about your
situation
number one i'm gonna send you a copy
of the book baby steps millionaires
that shows you what millionaires have
done we studied in the back of it is a
synopsis of the study a white paper of
the study of the largest study of
millionaires ever done in north america
airtight research so these are what is
are known as facts not opinions with
your broke brother-in-law okay
these are facts
now
the biggest thing that we found
was the biggest correlation that we
found among the first people to have a
million a million to a eight million
dollar five million dollar net worth the
first one to five million dollars in net
worth
comes from two things
a paid for house
and a fully funded rocking 401k roth ira
investment retirement program
okay
so we often found a 42 year old
um
that wasn't making anywhere near as much
as you're making and so it took them to
42
and they had a million in their 401 k
and a paid for 600 000 house so their
net worth was a million six
we found
thousands of those
that we interviewed they're all over the
place okay so what that tells us is if
you want to be one of those that's your
two best
routes to get there paid for house fully
funding loading up retirement
okay the danger of how the wonderful
experience you've had is it's the same
thing that happened to me in my 20s i
had 4 million worth of real estate by
the time i was 26 starting from nothing
and i thought i could just do that all
the time
and and i thought that i couldn't do
anything wrong and i i fell prey to and
i want to warn you against this the idea
that i could out earn my stupidity
no shot you know and it's because you've
been making bank and you can go well i
could i could screw this up and still be
okay you know and it's it's just hard to
do out here dave because uh you know i i
live in a place where what i call the
flex factor run ramp and it's uh a lot
of people you live in the ultimate flax
netflix neighborhood yeah indefinite
flex of all kinds yeah it's all flexes
there i get you
yeah for sure
and if you don't if you don't believe
that about miami just go to miami beach
okay so oh my gosh and uh uh
but it so yeah you can really fall off
into that and and start to believe your
own handwriting so be careful
i i would continue to make money and
continue to live like i'm not making any
money
for about two more years and you're
gonna have all the money you want for
the rest of your life probably
um
are you in our your single guy
yeah i i'm with my my girlfriend and uh
we're going on about four years now so
you know a couple of milestones are
definitely around the corner
for us you know uh getting married and
everything would it be okay to go make
another 500 in the next year and a half
and
bank that and then let's talk about
buying would that be okay
yeah no absolutely like i told her and
you know her parents are in in real
estate in there in the color bay area in
miami and i'm not in any rush and you
know i saw the show yesterday and you
know what you're saying is you know you
definitely don't want you definitely if
you're going to get an investment
property make sure you're getting a deal
it feels kind of hard to come by right
now no there's no
there's no deal yeah
well i was wondering if i should look
elsewhere you know just you know but i
don't know i mean if you want to move
inland and move uh what northwest out of
there um
you know a fort lauderdale direction you
know you you probably can
you probably can get your prices down
considerable and getting a lot more
reasonable thing if you want to go ahead
and get in the market that's fine i
don't i just don't hear an emergency
here for you to buy no i do want you to
buy in the next three years but i don't
know if i care if you buy in the next
three months
okay okay yeah well i have uh i get out
of this lease in you know february of
next year yeah so you know so what did
you would you suggest probably starting
to look into some other uh investments
maybe a mutual fund it didn't have to be
it's a year
it's not even a year it's february i
mean you're going to pile up so much
more how much more can you have by
february
um
to be honest i'd say
at least another 250. yeah
it's a different discussion right yeah a
little bit of movement northwest
and another 250 in february
changes i just think that you know and
then just be careful to not try to out
earn your stupidity
and and i i think you're a sharp young
dude man i'm proud of you you're killing
it i love entrepreneurs michael well
done and if there's a ring on her finger
she may have a say on where you guys are
going to live too if you get married so
yeah if you buy a house when you're a
single guy after you get married you'll
discover you bought the wrong house so
this is the ramsay show